ciao a tutti ragazzi il pensiero di oggi
è che c'è poco da fare non c'è niente di
peggio di chi si prende troppo sul serio
se l'inter ato in questa categoria
fatevi un favore cambiate oppure fate un
doppio carpiato in un tritacarne perché
facendo così diventate sempre meno buoni
meno dolci e dolci
secondo me sarei un ottimo pasticciare
se volessimo per un buon tiramisù
servono 300 g di zucchero e 500 di
mascarpone anche se tirarsi su sarà
impossibile visto che un bilancio senza
batteria a segno della bilancia viene
dopo quello della vergine così come la
vergine viene sempre dopo ma solitamente
non viene affatto
e se viene non è più vergine ma
smettiamo le chiacchierate e parliamo di
chi sa niente adesso dopo un lungo
periodo un passato in testa si insieme
ai cavalli ritorna sul palco anna
montagna
ok è arrivato il momento della verità
quello che è successo nel ranking
davanti ai vecchi cowboy orsi gare non
si ripeterà qua non può ripetersi più
adesso sono un po ma persona grazia
quieta i puledri parla con questa quel
palco a nadal conquista di dubbi col tuo
pezzo da cavallo qualcuno mi può
spiegare perché è un film serve inserire
questo training autogeno prima di salire
sul palco perché si parla senza motivo
alcuno
in un momento in cui dovessi solamente
non lo so perdere feci dal terrore come
eco come fanno le lumache i delfini le
asine io non so come facciano una di
film e riescono sempre a fargli fare
somme considerazioni nei momenti meno
opportuni
così si sta tutto si perda il cpa
congratulazioni mi chiedo come tu abbia
fatto sono riuscito a entrare in
possesso per il lievito accesso della
società grazie all'intervento di un
tirannosauro rex e al suo i manager di
fitch al prossimo ai fini dell insulina
ma chi è già una cosa
poi cui ci siamo tanti
mario eliminare della tv o film così mi
fa sperare che arrivino gli alieni prima
possibile a foderarsi le budella disse
sì ok ci piace chiacchierare né nei
reality show alla prova del cuoco
quando veniamo eletti presidenti delle
nazioni unite dobbiamo fare un discorso
all'america quello sì ma durante un
attacco alieno noi molto probabilmente
faremo così alla fine gli animi sono
arrivati lì mi sono trovato a salsa e
infine arriviamo a quello che secondo me
è un prodotto di pura fantascienza che
combina insieme la capacità di volare la
telepatia e una rete di 27 m 3000
finalmente rinato riscontro
ed i tuoi occhi
porco che ribolle dentro i tuoi dubbi e
mi attacca però questa volta non sarà
per me la sera per la mia famiglia e
soprattutto è così credo che possa
bastare
vado a cospargersi di benzina